these emails that we send to media or
tastemakers people that we want to come
out to the premiere how much fluff do we
pack the email with the correspondence
with and then how soon we get to the
point we don't want to be too blunt the
one of you would be genuine but we know
that everybody likes a little bit of
praise so where's that fine line I got a
very good story I got a very good pitch
someone sent me a you know like
last week for Olly shorts I'm not saying
him to accept this film but they made a
compelling case basically they had
quotes from a lot of credible peoples
actually I'm sorry it wasn't he this
wasn't even a film this was a stage play
from an alumni and he was just one liner
saying this person said this about the
play this person said this about the
plate that's more of a review thing i
would say packing testimonials truth
testimonials about the project in the
film some out if you can get some pretty
good names credible names but i want to
get too fluffy get the corners in the
first paragraph who what when where why
um you know and then how do i buy
tickets and then who's in it um you know
the website link um you know hype it up
as far as world premiere because it is
your fax you got it not embellish but
state your fact this is the first time
this film is being shown publicly this
is the world premiere and then if you
get a talent that you say you got to put
the talent first I tell my clients we
work with the machines we don't have the
Disney budget but if you're working with
Disney we got to include them somehow
you know um work with the machines
figure out your student top selling
points and capitalize on them in your
headline in the opening you know if you
get this artist we got to use them
downtown independent that's a brand you
got to use a world premiere downtown
when we run you know use the machine to
use the big brand and use them first
that's not fluff that's facts and then
close from you your quote when you talk
about the film you put a quote in that
press release that's when you can kind
of you know pick yourself up we're
delighted to be having this one-week run
this film some good stuff it's a really
good juice but I would use the machines
he's the brand's now one thing we don't
have yet Theo is an talent sorry all
right brains and talent maybe I should
come back to this idea in terms of its
understanding what you're saying there I
mean how do you assess the selling
points you know I mean from what you've
seen the bar from Dubai promise what
would you say like these are the
definite selling points these are some
of the things that you should include in
your pitch good question i would say you
know the filmmakers you know look at us
were the people behind film courage you
know one of the top you know next
podcast to watch ranked by movie makers
the filmmakers you guys are the you know
you know you guys are are you ranked by
national magazine as people to watch so
you have to include that in your
branding filmmakers you know the talent
you know use the talent you know the
talent if they've had a very big
credible a TV series of our movie that
they were on you got to include that you
know you got to include that up early
you know that's what sells that's what
people want to care about what am I
gonna go to this movie all right this
person was in this movie I'll crab
article or these guys are all these are
the guys behind dunkers I gotta go to
this I said the downtown independent all
right I gotta go there it's only
available for one week I got this is
something I got an attend you know I'm
telling you this from a media
perspective
and the media perspective is the
consumer perspective they want to see
the brand you know from your day what do
we need to do no yeah I mean I think you
uh you need to send out a media advisory
and invite even if it's not a me divisor
a general advisory to everyone that's
attending and then a day before you send
me a reminder tomorrow is our world
premiere media day you got to have your
American it's kind of step and repeat or
if you don't have a budget first step
and repeat you know posters you can
print up some really good posters on
phone cord and easel you see a lot of
independent films do this and then you
can do set up to the photos have your
talent arrive early and yourselves and
then you invite some good people that
can interview you on the carpet or
taking some good photos that you can use
and those photos can stay online forever
um and then you know staying with the
immediate advisory what goes into that
exactly very similar to press release
but it's more about who what when where
why and it's very short like a one pager
that says this is the premier world
premiere this is where it's happening
you know if you want to interview US you
know please contact us you know advisory
is important because it's so it's almost
kind of like a reminder this is
happening if there's a new story that's
been written about it already that's
fine but they still get the media you
could use it's not just for media it's
for everybody you know it's kind of like
a tune in tune in alert like let's say
you do an interview on TV on the wheels
channel um it's going to air tonight you
know your publicist would tune in alert
and you can send it to all your contacts
and say wash reelzchannel because then
they can watch they can tweet about it
they can talk about
and sometimes media picks up media
advisories to them maybe the post it
online you know me advisories important
any type of literature that we should
have at the screen mmm good question
yeah I'm skipping I'm missing a lot of
stuff yeah I mean if you prepared a
press kit if you prepare to press kit
definitely have that if not having one
page or press release but yeah I mean
bios of your key cast buyers of
yourselves one sheets like if there's a
you know if you've done um you know like
i said the poster but if you got like a
like a like a one-page glossy photo the
theatrical poster of your film you
should have that i'll so let me go back
up you shouldn't tell the downtown
independent or your screening room if
the habit capabilities put your one
sheet and their mark you know put your
name in the marquee possible if that's a
bar your negotiation definitely have
that available and then you know make
sure that your your posters are
available you know are made you gotta
have some branding up there you know
then you should have handouts and then
just cool unique stuff that you can do
to you should do some prizes at the end
some giveaways with the audience you
know get some free copies of the movie
um you know we were we do a ton of like
cool giveaways sometimes and then and
then yeah so I mean I would entice that
audience as well to continue the word of
mouth chatter and tell them you know
guys when you're doing your introduction
speech and you talk about making it a
film and everything you know please tell
your friends that this little indian
movie that code is available here and
downtown independent entice more people
to come you know i mean a lot of the
oscar films a lot of the independent
oscar films or documentaries for say
they rely strongly on word of mouth you
know to get national following because a
lot of the documentaries don't have the
budgets similar to the massive studio
houses sometimes these are very small
independent homes and I've watched them
and they're very strategic and they
capitalized on social media and the
capitalize on word of mouth and then get
people saying things you know
that reciprocate that nationwide I mean
for instance there's a cool thing that
good morning america does that you guys
can replicate I think you guys have done
this to it's like you know you capture
people saying interesting things I think
what the GMA say they were like say
three things that you like about the
Oscars or think three things about your
film it's like three words or something
and say creatively or something that
people will write them on note cards and
and put them in they create like this
national thing where it's on good
morning america and everyone's talking
about about their movies and that's how
they're promoting their films can be
something you know there's all types of
creative ways that are non traditional
media that you can use you know and
speaking of budget what if the budget is
therefore a glossy handout is it okay to
have something that's just sort of
something you photograph yeah put the
coffee machine and snow handmade looking
yeah how much like you no rules no rules
apply here bottom line is you got to be
creative and it's there's got to be some
kind of selling point e to your to your
audience and then you got to be creative
with some type of scene 2 in the film
maybe there's a scene that really kind
of um all right let's go backwards um
there is a film i just saw god i just
aired on TV it's the cedar rapids right
cedar rapids now it's different we're
talking about studio budget right but in
sundance two years ago the guys are so
creative they knew what the theme is of
their film right theme is core theme is
it's an insurance this is an insurance
guy you know and he's going out on this
incredible adventure for the first time
to look to a convention a national
convention that he's never been to
before and he's got to represent this
company and save the company so you know
the movie was already picked up i feel
before what the sundance but these guys
rented out a um like a
just kind of restaurant space or
something in sunday and something turned
it into a insurance office you know and
so they use that as a backdrop to do
their interviews and their cast
briefings and everything so you got to
find some kind of theme in the film that
um you can capitalize on and make some
kind of experience with it you know
something creative you know and then
that becomes a theme and then the
audience resonates too and they're like
oh that's what that is and then you can
tell it you can invite your influencers
to check it out so I know we're dealing
with a short time crunch but keep that
in mind there's always some kind of
theme that you can bring it tie into and
you know with this guerilla filmmaking
nation you can tap in social to you know
I mean the tumble you can have developed
that tumblr page develop you know
develop everything should be
reciprocated everywhere you know like um
do some kind of cool video drop it on
YouTube you know have a route you know
put that link when you're sitting out
your blast and say check out the special
board from I don't know so you can do
some very creative stuff right now that
creates viral buzz that will be drive
audiences to your phone you know whether
it be a special video special message
someone saying something a testimonial
campaign the thing about viral is you
got it tap into traditional as well so
when you're sending out the media blast
to your folks and you're having your
folks send it out link it to the YouTube
that you created or link it to the
tumblr page that you created tap into
traditional that's what's going to help
your viral
you